Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David P..
We've talked about the faux border crisis,
here is a right wing caller, very Trumpy and
guy who continues to ask about the border
crisis.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: When are you going to cover the
border crisis?
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Listen, we've been covering the facts of the
situation at the border.
One of those facts is that the Biden administration,
they've not handled the border perfectly.
There's no.
They've done nothing really on immigration
that's permanent yet.
But the number of migrant children who are
awaiting being reunited with their families
has dropped dramatically.
From March to April.
It dropped dramatically.
The crisis is a crisis concocted by public
relations and concocted by Republican communications
offices and concocted by right wing media.
That's the simple reality of the situation.
We had a situation at the border and immigration
not dealt with under the Trump administration.
We have a situation at the border and the
immigration situation not dealt with under
the Biden administration.
Some improvements have been made under Joe
Biden, but this was their concerted effort
and the voice mail is proof that it worked.
And there's polling that tells us at work,
even though you and I might remember what
was going on at the border under Trump, what's
going on under Biden and say it's slightly
better but not resolved.
Right.
Underwhelming, but that's the reality.
It's slightly better, but not resolved.
If you look at polling back in June of twenty
twenty, only twenty eight percent of Americans
believed that immigration and the border were
a serious and top issue.
Now, about a month and a half ago, 48 percent
of Americans almost doubling believe that
the situation at the border and immigration
is serious and crisis level.
So, yes, they decided, hey, we need to create
a scandal for Joe Biden.
Yes, it's a fake scandal, but it has worked
and it has convinced millions of people when
something goes from twenty eight to forty
eight percent in American society, that's
tens of millions of people that have been
convinced of something.
It has worked.
And, you know, I don't know what else this
guy wants me to say.
We've covered what's going on at the border
and it's slight improvement from the situation
that Trump left us.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Andrew Yang is going after a tabloid for what
he is calling a racist cartoon that referred
to him as a tourist.
We're going to talk about that on the bonus
show today.
Small business owners in Manhattan are increasingly
getting unbelievably well located businesses
as a result of the pandemic.
We'll talk about where, who, why and what
the implications are.
And the Texas House has voted to pull funding
from sports teams that do not play the national
anthem before sporting events, which, of course,
they don't actually have to do.
But this is the latest vertue signal from
Republicans.
It's something that doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really do anything for the middle
class, working people, businesses, education.
It's nonsense.
It's virtue signaling, but it probably polls
pretty well with a lot of Republican voters.
And so that's what the Texas House has voted
on.
We will talk about all of those stories and
more when producer Pat joins me on today's
bonus show, Get Access Instantly by signing
up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
And remember that Monday, Memorial Day.
Now, just a few days away, we will be doing
a single day membership bomb explosion.
We're going to do a single day discount off
of membership's.
We're trying to rebuild some of the lost memberships
over the last couple of months due to covid.
If you want to be notified of that absolutely
perfect membership special on Monday, just
get on my newsletter, which you can do.
So you can do at David Pakman Dotcom upper
right of the website.
You type in your email address, you'll be
on the newsletter and Monday you'll be notified
of that special coupon code.
But for people who are already signed up,
we will see you in mere moments
on today's phone.